muchos nervios y expectación en el
inicio de esta jornada histórica en
chile ya están abiertos en este momento
todos los colegios electorales en el
país en un día que también ha estado
marcado por un supuesto cambio de hora
que no ocurrió y que hizo que muchos de
celulares de personas cambiaran de hora
y por lo tanto se han presentado incluso
antes de lo habitual a los lugares de
votación vemos muchísima gente con
respecto a otras votaciones que hemos
transmitido en ocasiones anteriores hay
un ambiente de efervescencia de
incertidumbre también ante lo que va a
pasar en estas primeras elecciones con
voto obligatorio desde 2012 que también
van a movilizar movilizar a un número
mucho mayor de personas que traicionen
un país en el que tradicionalmente el
voto ha sido escaso o ha sido con poca
participación en procesos electorales y
ese plebiscito ha dividido a chile y tal
como usted lo mencionó muy brevemente
actualmente hay una incertidumbre
cuéntanos qué está ocurriendo en el país
así es mientras que las encuestas dan
como favorito al rechazo la opción del
rechazo también vimos una gran
manifestación de personas que salieron a
celebrar el cierre de campaña de la
prueba la cuestión es cuántas personas
van a venir a votar de esos votantes que
no votan tradicionalmente y por qué
opción se va a decantar las opciones
están abiertas no se sabe bien qué es lo
que va a pasar pero ya hay previstas
varias opciones desde el punto de vista
institucional en el caso de que gane una
u otra opción para continuar con el
proceso de cambios que se inició con el
estallido social en chile en el año 2010
y no